now let's head downtown one of the
oldest local dive bars is getting a
fresh start Rocky is live at the Hard
Hat Lounge previewing the future of this
piece of Vegas history hi Rocky
hey ladies yes the grand reopening of
this iconic bar is this weekend on
Saturday in particular but we've got the
owners the besties and business owners
here we've got Robbie Cunningham of
gorilla Pizza we call him a pizza
Liberty that's okay and then we've got
local rock star Vegas's very own rock
star Frank sodoris here okay you guys
you met in a bar yeah so uh we're in
alignment in alignment that is correct
uh we met about six years ago
um randomly at a bar I was bartending at
and uh have been played the right music
that night and uh we ended up kind of
starting a little cover gig cover band
together and uh we've been friends for
quite a few years and here we are here
we are could would you say owning a dive
bar was one of your lifelong dreams I've
spent a lot of time on the other side of
the bar and I felt like
yeah well welcome to the other side
welcome to the other side now what would
make um The Hard Hat Lounge a landmark
uh so honestly one of the most iconic
things about the bar if you've been in
here uh we have this 1962 uh mural from
Frank Bowers
um that he actually painted for uh to
cover a bar tab that he racked up inside
the bar so uh you know it doesn't get
cooler than that iconic straight from
the 1960s and Frank you know you guys
really want to preserve the historical
charm obviously but how are you making
it new how are you making it fresh I
assume you're bringing in the music
element oh absolutely eventually we'll
have some live music outside we'll be
able to shut down the parking lot bring
in some you know big shows for the most
part we'll definitely have some live
music inside but we've been you know
karaoke nights industry nights trying to
really invite the uh the strip to us you
know bring them down industrial exactly
yeah bring them bring them to downtown
where it's where where we get real okay
so now Pete celebrity sir what's on the
menu gorilla Pizza uh so we have uh
Detroit we are doing Detroit style pizza
um we've got the um you know cheese all
the way to the edge of the crust sauce
on top right here we have sausage
pepperoni or sausage mushrooms peppers
and onions and then we got pepperoni
banana peppers and jalapeno on that side
okay
well obviously paired with a classic
beer last question here
dream bar guest who are you inviting in
wow dream bar guest uh
uh Paul McCartney let's go I love that
okay this weekend I gotta wrap I gotta
wrap Paul McCartney you're invited
Saturday here for the grand opening
carnival style you guys come on down
I'll send it back to you